okay i'll i just get
stronger position grandmaster krupa
again
ah now he now he accepts the bank home
for a change
played b6 before
i already screwed up my move order great
okay
yeah i think this is also
a known line not sure
hmm
hmm
no idm
maybe g5 or something
well before of course not after he
played e4
i don't know i don't know
i don't know um the usual
moves here
yeah this is already looking somewhat
depressing
i don't have any compensation here
hmm
how to get some play here
of course d7 is not the greatest place
for the bishop
uh
yeah this is just
just a bad position
i can also play nazi six even
didn't do it
oh no knight c6 yeah
yeah he plays it um simple it's
simple but strong
like it's just um
just the pawn down and um also
also have just the worst position
okay
wants to put a knight on b5 most likely
not much i can do them
this is some any sacrifices here
shouldn't lead to to anything
i was thinking maybe about this
get d5 in it's very weakening of course
but with normal moves i'm dead lost
anyway
so whatever
oh i forgot about this move
it's got bishop f5 but f4 if i take i
think
time warning
yeah i also know great tricks or
something
wow what a great game
yeah maybe i should simply resign but
yeah black
resigns
well yeah
the only line i know a bit here
this was knight f to d7 and then knight
to b6
and now i got into the main line we have
no idea about
and where it's actually questionable if
black has got anything decent anyway no
idea
yeah this was just um
just a wipeout if you don't know
your stuff in this kind of opening you
just get
destroyed by really strong rap master
maybe i
there are some ideas with g5 maybe but
this looks
really weird but i think g5 and queen f5
or something at least this would be
would make some sense in connection to
the moves before
i thought i could play this anyway but
after e4 of course this
whole setup doesn't make any sense and
now all my
pieces are bad so it's just a
clear edge for white yeah okay let's
hope the next game will bring a somewhat
more convenient opponent okay